اخفق وزيرا الخارجيه الامريكي جون كيري
والروسي سيرجي لافروف في التوصل الى اتفاق
لوقف اطلاق النار في حلب وذلك بعد
اجتماعين سريعين عقدهما الوزيران في
هامبورج على هامش لقاء دولي وكانت ست دول
غربيه قد دعت روسيا الاربعاء الى وقف
اطلاق نار فوري في مدينه
حلب
اهلا بكم كان هذا خبر حلقتنا ونناقش فيما
وراءه على ماذا تستند موسكو في تجاهلها
المستمر للنداءات الدوليه المتكرره بشان
هدله في حلب رغم تعاظم الماساه الانسانيه
في المدينه ثم ما هي خيارات المجتمع
الدولي اذاء استمرار التجاهل الروسي
لماسات حلب والدعوات الدوليه لوقف القتال
فيها
تحت رحمه موسكو يضع المجتمع الدولي نفسه
وهو يسعى الى تحقيق وقف اطلاق نار في حلب
ينقذ حياه سكان احيائها الشرقيه الذين
تتراوح تقديرات عددهم بين 150 و 200 الف
نسمه التقارير الانسانيه محليه ودوليه
تؤكد استحكام الازمه الانسانيه الخانقه في
حلب ورغم ذلك فقد واصلت موسكو اصرارها على
رفض كافه النداءات الدوليه الداعيه الى
وقف اطلاق النار في المدينه نتابع تقرير
فتحي اسماعيل ثم نفتح النقاش مع
ضيوفنا تغرق حلب في دماء قتلاها وجرحاها
تشتد الفاجعه ويتوسع مشهد الرحيل الكبير
عما بقي من المدينه المنكوبه فلا يزداد
مهاجمها الا نكايه وانتقاما من اهلها لا
يعرف الثمن الانساني المطلوب من اجل هدنه
مجرد هدنه لاخراج المصابين والاطفال
والنساء بعد ما انتهى امر اي اتفاق سياسي
مذ صارت السياسه كما الحرب بلا اخلاق
يتفوق الروس في ذلك وتشتد لاءات في وجه اي
مسع سلمي انساني مهما كان نوعه وايا كان
مصدره فعلى جدار التعنت الروسي اخفق احدث
اجتماع بين وزيري خارجيه موسكو وواشنطن
تبخر الامل الضئيل الذي سبق محادثات
هامبورك بالمانيا وغادر جون كيري خائبا
وخيبته تلك في جانب منها من صنع اداره
رئيسه نفسه التي اوصلها خيار الانكفاء الى
حد استجداء التسويات من روسيا قبل ذلك
رفضت موسكو دعوه لوقف اطلاق النار فورا في
حلب اطلقتها ست دول غربيه بينها الولايات
المتحده وفرنسا وبري
رغم تلويح المبادره بملاحقه مرتكبي
انتهاكات حقوق الانسان وجرائم الحرب في
سوريا لم يلتفت الروس اليها تحديا لتلك
الدول ول الام المتحده نفسها التي اكتفت
بالاعراب عن ترحيبها باي جهد يؤدي الى وقف
مستدام للاعمال العدائيه في حلب من خلال
الضغط على اطراف النزاع وهل بقي في حلب
اطراف للنزاع اصلا بل هل ظل فيها غير
قاذفات تدك من الجو وقوات وميليشيات
مهاجمه ارضا تطبق على احياء محاصره يعلق
فيها اكثر من 100 ال من الجوع والمرضى
ومعهم قتل تحت الانقاظ وجثث ملقاه في
الشوارع تعذر الوصول اليها وانتشالها رئيس
المجلس المحلي في حلب تحدث عن سقوط اكثر
من 800 قتيل مدني واصابه
3500 اخرين خلال الايام الاخيره بينما اكد
مندوب اتحاد المنظمات الطبيه الاغاثه
السوريه ان ما لا يقل عن 1500 شخص هم في
حاجه لاجلاء طبي سريع على خلفيه ذلك تقدمت
فصائل المعارضه في شرقي حلب بهدنيه
انسانيه فوريه من خمسه ايام لاخلاء
الحالات الطبيه الحرجه وتمكين السكان
الراغبين في المغادره من الخروج في خطوه
فندت ادعاء النظام وحلفائه باستخدام
المدنيين دروعا بشريه لكن الروس والنظام
رفضوا المبادره وقبلها بيومين قوض فيتو
روسي واخر صيني مشروع قرار في مجلس الامن
الدولي طالب بهدنيه من اسبوع لادخال
مساعدات للمدنيين المحاصرين في شرق
حلب موضوع حلقتنا هذا نناقشه مع ضيوفنا من
لندن بسام جعاره الكاتب والاعلامي السوريه
المعارض ومن موسكو اندري سبانو الخبير في
شؤون الشرق الاوسط ومن واشنطن اندرو تابلر
كبير الباحثين في معهد واشنطن لسياسات
الشرق الادنى نرحب بضيوفنا جميعا وابدا
معك في موسكو اندري ستيبانوف يعني حياه
يعني اكثر من 150 ما بين 150 الف الى 200
ال مدني في احياء حلب الشرقيه مرهونه الان
ب وافقه روسيه على هدنه لا تتعدى ايامها
ربما الاربعه او خمسه ايام لادخال
المعونات
الانسانيه يعني الى ماذا تستند موسكو
برايك في موقفها المتعنت المتعنت هذا في
رفض
هدنه لا في طبعا نلاحظ التعان ولكن ليس من
طرف موسكو ولكن من طرف
الارهابيين
المتشددين المتط رفين موسكو اقترحت غير مر
فتح ممرات لخروج سكان شرقيه حالب الى
اماكن امنه ولكن الارهابيون رفضوا كل كل
كل مره يعني وموسكو برغم من فاشل
المحادثات الاخيره
بين بين كيري ولافروف اظن ان موسكو يليح
على فتح الممار لخروج ما بين 8 و1 الا من
السكان المدنيين من شرقيه حالب من الاحياء
المحاصره
و طبعا هناك يعني كثير من التضليل للراي
العام والتشويه ل الواضع القائم يعني
موسكو طبعا بت تدرك ابعاد المسات
وسكان المنقبين في شرقيه حالب ولكن في
حاله واقف اطلاق النار فورا بدون اي شروط
مسب
اج سيد ستيبانوف لا يبدو هذا عمليا اذا
سند اذا ما قاله مستشار الامم المتحده
للشؤون الانسانيه اجلان ممثل الامم
المتحده للشؤون الانسانيه اجلان من ان اي
عرض لخروج المدنيين عبر ممرات امنه دون
التوصل الى وقف لاطلاق النار يعتبر شيئا
في الفراغ لا معنى له
لا الشرط الاساسي لوقف اطلاق النار يعني
موافقه الارهابيين والمتطرفين على
مغادره المناطق المحاصره وتم الاتفاق اولا
منذ اسبوع بين لافروف وكيري بخصوص تخديد
خطوط السير والتوقيتات لمغادره الارهابيين
لتلك المناطق وبعد ذلك يمكن ايسا اي نوع
من الاغاثه وتقديم اي مساعده الطبيه
والانسانيه
والغذائيه يعني
لسكان تلك احياء ولكن هناك يعني دموع
التماسيح الرب
همه ما رايك بهذا الكلام من ان موسكو لا
تعارض في الواقع وقف اطلاق النار والتوصل
الى هدنه ولكن
المعارضه بكل اطياف هي التي يعني تعرقل
هذا
الامر اولا بدي اذكر امس عندما اجتمعت
المعارضه مع وف الاتحاد الاوروبي هي من
طلبت هدنه خمسه ايام هذا يعني ان كذبه
الروس عن استخدام المدنيين كدروع بشريه هو
كلام كاذب من يحتفظ بالمدنيين ك دروع
بشريه لا يطلب اخراج المدنيين وخاصه
الحالات الحرجه ثانيا منسق الامم المتحده
اللي استشهدت فيه حضرتك قال حرفيا منذ
خمسه اشهر نتفاوض مع الروس دون دون جدوى
كانوا يتحدثون عن ممر كليست كوستيلو
يقولوا انه غير امن ثم قالت روسيا انه امن
انا رح اقول لك ماذا يريد الروس الان هم
يريدوا تنفيذ سيناريو جروزني حرفيا حصار
تدمير قتل ثم اخراج السكان والمسلحين
الروس طلبوا اخراج الجميع وقال لافروف امس
ان كيري في الثاني من الشهر الجاري وافق
على اخراج الجميع ولكن ما يقال في الغرف
المغلقه شيء وما يقال في الاعلام شيء اخر
ايضا انا بدي اعقب عن موضوع اخفاق كيري
كيري لم يخفق كيري متفق مع الروس على
اسقاط حلب وعندما اجتمع اوباما مع قاده
الغرب قبل ع ايام طلبوا فرض عقوبات على
روسيا رفض اوباما ورفض بعض الاوروبيين
ايضا بمعنى الجميع متفق على اسقاط حلب
ولكن الكذب الروسي مستمر والقتل مستمر من
يريد الحفاظ
على ارواح المدنيين لا يقصف المدنيين نحن
نتحدث عن اكثر 150 الف محكوم عليهم
بالاعدام وتريد روسيا ان تنفذ في حلب ما
جرى في دريه وما جرى في الباب كل الكلام
الروسي كاذب هم يحاولون شراء الوقت بمعنى
اما ان تخرجوا من حلب واما فان القضاء
عليكم سيكون مبرما امس قال الكرملين صراحه
لم يتبقى في حلب الارهابيين هم يعتبرون
اكثر من 150 ال حلبي هم مجموعه من
الارهابيين السؤال المطروح اذا كانت
امريكا متفقه معهم واذا كان الغرب صامت
يكتفي فقط بالبكاء يعني فلماذا ستوافق
روسيا على هدنه او على وقف اطلاق نار لن
توافق ابدا لان الجميع اتفق على اسقاط ح ه
هو اتفاق وسؤال لاندرو تابلر نعم عندما
يقول بسام جعاره كيري يعني لم يخفق ولكن
كيري متفق مع نظيره الروسي على اسقاط حلب
وان امريكا متواطئه يعني هنا نتحدث عن
حاله تواطؤ وليس حاله عجز ما رايك بهذا
الكلام كلا كلا هذا غير مقبول ليس هناك اي
تواطؤ في هذا السياق كما تعلمون ليس هناك
اتفاق ما بين الولايات المتحده وروسيا
حيال حلب حول طرفان الاوصول غير مره
لاتفاق حول هذا الملف ولكن هناك الكثير من
الامور العالقه لان روسيا ما زالت ترى في
بقاء الاسد شيئا ضروريا وما زال هناك من
قبل الروس محاصره لحلب وتجويع
المدنيين المشكل في هذا السياق في حقيقه
الامر هذا ما تعبر عنه المعارضه ان الولا
المتحده لا تقوم بشيء لوقف هذه المعاناه
هناك طبعا اداره امريكيه منتهي ولاياتها
الاداره الحاليه لم تريد ان تتدخل في
سوريا والنظام السوري وروسيا يحاولان الان
سحق
المعارضه على امل ان تمضي الامور في
الاتجاه الذي يريدانه ولا اعتقد ان هناك
اي
تواطؤ بعد سوف ناخذ الان فاصلا قصيرا ولكن
سنناقش بعد هذا الفاصل ما الذي يمكن
بالفعل يعني ان يقدمه او يفعله العالم سوى
اطلاق النداءات وال الاستجداء من اجل
ارغام موسكو على انهاء تجاهلها لنداءات
بشان حلب فنرجو الا تبتعدوا كثيرا سوف
[موسيقى]
نعود
ا
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم من جديد الى حلقتنا هذه ونعود
الى ضيوفنا اندري سبانو في موسكو واضح ان
روسيا وضعت نفسها اليوم في مواجهه
دبلوماسيه مع العالم كله تكاد تكون اليوم
دوله مارقه في نظر العالم يعني من اجل
ماذا كل هذا هل يصدق ان هذا كله من اجل
مبدا حمايه المؤسسات الشرعيه في سوريا كما
كانت تدعي في البدايه
لا هناك اولا لا لا يمكن القول ان العالم
كل ضد ضد مواقف روسيا
وايران وسوريا يعني واما زعماء تلك الدول
اظن ان
سياحه سوريا تتميز
بالهوائيه والدماغ وجيه يعني ويعني زعزعه
الهواء فقط يعني لكسب اي نفوذ السياسي ولا
يتوقع الى الى تحركات الفعليه اما
المعارضه السوريه ومن الصعب اجراء الحوار
معها لان نستمع
دائما المعارضه نفس يعني اطلقت اطلقت
مبادره لوقف اطلاق النار وتبناها الاتحاد
الاوروبي وهي مبادره لدنه لمده خمسه ايام
يعني تبدو يعني واضح انها في موقع من
بادر لا الشرط الاساسي اجلاء الارهابيين
او يعني تجريد الاحياء المحاصره من
الارهابيين بعد ذلك يعني ليس هناك ايه
مانع
توص والى تقديم اي مساعده طبيه يعني مين
يتكلم حضرتك ولا انا يعني اذا حضرتك تعرف
كل شيء تعرف في كل شيء يعني اهلا وسهلا
ليش الدعوه للاشتراك في المك مكالمات يعني
لس نحن نسالك عن وجهه النظر الروسيه س بال
الانحياز باستمرار يعني تفضل
تفضل اه اه اه وطبعا طبعا يعني و انا فاهم
موقف الغرب والمعارضه السوريه لانهم
خاسرون خاسرون ولا مفار من القداء على
بقايا المقاومه داخل الاحياء المحاصره اما
السكان الابرياء تم تحرير الجزء الاكبر
من شرقي حلب والناس من هناك يتحدثون
بصراحه بمعامله الهرابي لهؤلاء الناس
بالكع
وبتجوز
الاغاثه كوسيله الدخل عليهم واساليب
استخدامهم كدروع بشعريه وكرين يعني
الفعليه وهذا يكشف كل كل يعني التلفيقات
والادا للدعايه الغربيه التي تتفق مع بعض
وسا الاعلام العربيه يعني بهذا الخصوص اما
مصير السكان الابرياء ممكن الاستماع الى
من غدر
غادروا الاحيا المحاصره هناك كل العنايه
هناك يعني توزيع لغاز يعني بالكثره وهذا
يفد ي النفاق الغربي تجاه حالب يعني
اعطيناك اكثر من من الوقت اكثر من بقيه
الضيوف رغم انك زعلان سيد ستيبانوف استاذ
بسام جعاره يعني الان ماذا ننتظر يعني هل
سيبقى الوضع كما هو عليه العالم كله يعني
كل المناشدات والاستجداء العالم غسل يديه
من من روسيا واضح انها ماضيه في سياستها
ولا تعبر احدا ما هي البدائل ما هي
الخيارات
الان يعني اسمحي لي اقول اولا بس ضيفك
اللي عم يحكي على الابرياء هو من يقتل
الابرياء بالقنابل العنقوديه والفراغيه
وبكل انواع الاسلحه من البر والبحر والجو
بل يتشدق وزير الدفاع ويقول بكل صفاقه
انهم يجربون اسلحتهم على اهل حلب هؤلاء
عباره عن مجرمين هذا اولا ثانيا لضيفك
الامريكي بدي يذكره وحدايه حمايه الشعب
الكرديه اللي عم تموله وتسلح امريكا هي من
احكمت الحصار على حلب من جهتها بمعنى اخر
امريكا شريك حقيقي في الحصار انا بدي اصل
ضيفك الامريكي لو قال له لافروف لو قال له
كير لافروف اذا لم تفك الحصار سوفر السلاح
المضاد للطائرات هل كان الحصار سيستمر
يوما واحدا لماذا رفض اوباما فرض عقوبات
على روسيا هم متامر معا يعني كل الكلام
الامريكي كاذب ضيفك تحتس الان عن مرحله
انتقاليه بمجيء ترامب ولكن الموقف
الامريكي لم يتغير ابدا منذ الييوم الاول
لماذا يمنعون السما يعون المض اندرو تابلر
هل سيتغير
سن انت ترى انه لن يتغير سيد تبر على
الاطلاق نعم هل سيتغير برايك الموقف
الامريكي الان مع قدوم الاداره الجديده ام
سنبقى على ما هو عليه الحال من ضعف في
السياسه الامريكيه تجاه موسكو فيما يتعلق
بسوريا يبدو ان ضيفنا لا يسمعنا في واشنطن
اذا استاذ بسام جعاره لك ان تواصل فكرتك
بخصوص الموقف الامريكي تقول انه لن يتغير
وستبقى السياسه الامريكيه كما هي عليه من
الضعف في المرحله الحاليه اليس
كذلك
اكي اكيد اكيد والموقف الغربي يتبع الموقف
الامريكي حاولت فرنسا في فتره ما ان تفعل
شيئا منعتها امريكا مشكلتنا ليست في القصر
الروسي فقط بل في التواطؤ الامريكي الذي
يمنع الشعب السوري من الدفاع عن نفسه
امريكا تلعب منذ خمسه اشهر وهم يتحدثون عن
ادخال مساعدات ويعطون روسيا الوقت لتدمير
كل شيء روسيا تقوم بدور وظيفي كما النظام
تماما هذا ما تريده امريكا ولكن باداه
روسيه منذ خمس سنوات ونحن ندفع ثمن اللعب
الامريكي والتواطؤ الامريكي على شعبنا سيد
تابلر ان كنت اندرو تسمعني
الان سيد
تابلر لا اذا اندرو تبل الرس معنا اعود
اليك في موسكو سيد اندري ستيبانوف ال
المرحله ال المقبله برايك هل ستبقى كما هي
عليه يعني السياسه الروسيه لن تتغير ستبقى
هكذا على حاله استقواء فيما يتعلق بالوضع
في سوريا وتحديدا في
حلب لا اجن ان التحرير الشرقيه حالب هذا
امر محكوم محكوم نهائيا يعني ولكن
تبعا تحرير الشرقيه حالب
لا يعني
يعني نهايه للحرب الاهليه وطبعا موسكو
اظون
ستعتبر هذه العمليه نجاحا تكتيكيا فقط
ولوضع الحاد للعمليات الحربيه وللوصول الى
المصالحه الوطنيه من
ال تب الينا الان في اقل من دقيقه نعم في
في نصف دقيقه اندرو تابلر كيري سيقول
سنواصل اتصالاتنا مع مع روسيا هل معنى هذا
ان هناك
امل نعم نعم الامل مازال موجودا ولكن هو
يتضاءل مع مر الوقت ولا اعتقد ان التواصل
مع روسيا سيكون مثمرا لان راينا ما كانت
تقوم به روسيا من مناورات ومغالطات في
الاونه الاخيره وهناك الكثير من المؤشرات
التي تشير الى هذا الولايات المتحده
ستحاول جاهده ان تحقق تقدما في هذا السياق
ولكن ربما هذا لن يتاتى لها شكرا لك شكرا
لضيوفنا جميعا وبهذا تنتهي هذه الحلقه الى
اللقاء
عاود طيان